[Music]
seriously how long do you think they'll
wait before they put a replica of the
castle from the Magic Kingdom right
between the two and the zero Jesus
Christ if you're gonna subvert something
maybe try working on these 36 seconds of
logos hang on this is ultimately a
pretty apartment right but there's a
six-burner stove that's like chef
quality also if he's trying to get a
bunch of gas in here why didn't dpe turn
on a last burner on the end and now the
pink stove controls are turned every
which way rather than being on the
maximum effort setting we just saw
Deadpool put them on my point in is why
can't this movie fucking stove correctly
just because you're a Deadpool movie
doesn't get you out of a showing a love
story through a photo collage montage
cliche sit Wolverine sitting Deadpool
for narration is like sending
chocolate-chip cookies because they
contain chocolate chips but I actually
prefer a chocolate chip list chocolate
chip cookies and we've got a job to do
here so narration yes what will be I'm
dying in this one too yeah but not
really you're asking for an emotional
payoff for multiple fake out deaths in
this movie at least Logan had the
decency to stay deceased
I don't speak Cantonese mr. funny joke
but did Deadpool seriously come all the
way to Hong Kong without knowing this
motherfuckers name what kind of plan was
this and how long was he waiting in
there is this really more effective than
say jumping out from behind a tree or
was Ryan just longing to relive his time
on the Buried set see Captain America
yeah dude there are some great King
shout outs to other superheroes in
multiple universes but doesn't this one
feel forced like other than spraying the
funeral with bullets couldn't cap do all
the Deadpool's doing here sure we are
far enough away to not see that it's
Wade doing some Deadpool dancing why are
these guys right up front still cheering
like they think it's Demi Moore from 20
years ago
aside from the fact that these Jacuzzi
Yakuza have caught a bad case of one at
a time I just why doesn't a single one
of them have a gun on them no one
thought to bring it to koozie Uzi also
despite that I've got to give it up for
the fight choreography in this movie
Jesus who even thinks up fights like
this dozens of severed arms legs and
heads but yes please blur this man's
giggle stick because who will think of
the children
that babysitter of yours is high as damn
I like to party I know we want to see
all the back good action behind him but
how is this asshole supposedly running
at top speed when the stuff behind him
is happening in real time
little pokey can't maintain address and
thus begins the annoying trend of the
exact same beat from the first movie
happening in the sequel remember when I
couldn't have fun food and Deadpool to
expects us to remember the dopinder
F story from the last movie look I've
seen the first Deadpool dozens of times
and even I forgot that pattern yet who
have those dreams grabbed those dreams
by the tip and make it rain I don't know
what that means I don't know what that
means there's a cheap and easy beat in
the comedy movie cliche diarrhea we
can't be sure till I get the suit off
but all signs point to yes and Deadpool
movies have as many poop jokes as a
goddamn Shrek movie and I'm sending that
crap number one it totally taints this
franchise and is a stain on the logo
rheic nature of the dialogue and number
two it wipes clean any of the goodwill
from the more intelligent humor might
want to dump on us later baby factory's
open for business oh my god oh that's
sweet but like most superheroes that
choose to procreate you got to wonder
about some things like how much
Deadpool's mutilated DNA would affect a
fetus
see ok with potentially having offspring
that is impervious to death does he even
have sperm that could fertile oh wait
this totally means but nothing's gonna
die so we won't have to think any
further about this you are not your
father I know we're trying to squeeze
some substance into this sequel but it's
just really what we're here for
if Deadpool knows he's in a movie he
should know that she's about to bite it
right wait Deadpool somehow develop
spidey sense sort of Morgan Freeman
trained him to do this by getting his
ass kicked by Angelina Jolie considering
Deadpool is extremely aware of his
inability to die wouldn't he'd do
everything he can to push this fight out
into the hallway to protect someone he
knows is vulnerable instead of you know
diving across a counter and ducking out
a sight to give them more time to shoot
up the place okay since this moment sets
the entire plot in motion let's break it
down show me first even beyond the
character says I'm okay but then
surprise they are an okay cliche
why is this final gunman waiting so long
let's see a big Deadpool fanboy and just
couldn't attack until he heard a good
cheese spreader joke
second Deadpool has time to recognize
the look on her face completely turn
around and throw the spreader but
discount Inara doesn't have time to
quickly drop to the floor third wade has
wrapped up each previous baddie in the
scuffle with inhumanely accurate knife
throwing skills but here he not only
misses the vital organs he completely
misses the entire person and force where
if I see one more person turn their head
and follow a slow-mo bullet in the movie
I will force-feed the entirety of
Hollywood toaster strudels with Manny's
icing totally Sergei went
exactly where Deadpool guests like he
could have hidden in the hallway for a
while and scape easily do we have to do
these credits with all the in jokes
again isn't the bomb parity and the
genuinely good Celine Dion song enough
it's like saying narration or roll
credits or logos man in every video wait
you smell like sauerkraut left in the
warm rain
this goes on for some time and gets
progressively less funny just trust me
are you pissing are you urinating right
now you're making the face that you make
me your name hi
lowest-common-denominator
I'd like to place an order for one piss
joke for Deadpool - sure hope they're
tied up in a complicated deal with the
despicable me franchise I thought you
saw me with your ears man it's hard to
overstate how these movies would be if
anyone other than Ryan Reynolds was
playing this character I'm conflicted on
whether this qualifies as a sin yeah
this movie rips off Groundhog Day even
worse than happy deathday also until he
gets to the gasoline trick in the
apartment how that would wait expect any
of this crap to kill him he's clearly
survived much worse so this is really
just for the audience hey it looks like
Wade made it to the upside down there's
something here I can't take it - are we
really supposed to buy into this emotion
you can't spend three minutes asking me
to take you seriously and the rest of
the time making dick infer jokes while
breaking every fourth wall in sight he
says self-referential II I feel like the
writers used all their supply of villain
nuance on cable and said get to the rest
of the bad guys so is there the same
fight between humans and mutants in this
universe as there is in the x-men
universe seems like Deadpool and the
other mutants are able to operate with
impunity with no resistance from humans
but here they drop us into a mutant
conversion facility with barely a
mention of the underlying politics some
ground rules well under our roof number
one but Colossus has the handbook
halfway open did they seriously wait
until the goddamn middle of the book to
start talking about the rules also
pretty sure Colossus would have the
rules memorized by this point especially
you know the first one about not killing
anyone
I said how long has Wade been here he's
just now getting introduced to the rules
and meeting ntw and ukyo for the first
time but he's super well healed after
having been blown all the way up doesn't
that take a long time to reverse and how
does he even heal I've never seen his
parts reattached before they just grow
back so did this body eventually sprout
from his head I'm just saying the whole
aftermath of the catastrophic suicide
attempt is way yada-yada seer hilarious
bit truly a laugh-out-loud moment but
why what are the x-men doing in there I
couldn't lead here or see them before
that why wouldn't they want to talk to
wait anyway
yes who killed Vanessa car away he means
himself so this is really just a slight
modification of the pronoun game and you
know how we feel about that around here
I'm gonna tell you what the big lie is
toilet paper geez between this
interstellar thor ragnarok unsane the
third wheel and team america it's clear
that Matt Damon would rather cameo for
the rest of his career than trained for
another fuckin Bourne movie the PFAs
colossus doing calisthenics for this is
metallic shape really require cardio
something wrong it's fine just filled it
so this implies weighed literally jerked
off into the soap dispenser right is
that the joke and why would colossus
even use soap and water anyway god this
movie definitely decided to go with
quantity over quality for the jokes
that's a terrible idea
I'm really not ready it Swedes plan here
I know he's faking like he's found some
heart and he's playing by the rules of
the mansion but is he really content
with sitting around the house I thought
he wanted to be involved this kid needs
to be the icebox not here
Russell Provence in our care man this
sure is a casual conversation to be
having while only several feet away from
an out-of-control fire throwing mutant
sure rustles in a temper tantrum but why
is he taking it out on the x-men they're
the only ones that are actually trying
to talk to it and they're clearly one of
his own despite the other two going
straight backwards as a result of
Russell's fireball Deadpool somehow
curves up into this window just so we
can get a super force Wolverine Ryan
Reynolds Joe it's the perfect way for
Deadpool did not cross all out of the
picture and is a beautiful shot holy
that's awesome so the human police have
collar restraints for the mutants like
once they get that technology and if
it's available why the hell is the
headmaster using that throat device that
clearly doesn't work you let me down
the last time Jesus can we give Colossus
anything else to do except try and fail
to rehabilitate wait this is like the
least efficient prison ever made why
have the cells so far apart why is there
so much room it's not like they need to
mitigate any mutant powers that's what
the suddenly convenient hours are for my
whole life I've been waiting for someone
to come and save me know what he's gonna
sacrifice anything for me sacr
foreshadowing also this underscores my
question about Russell's behavior
outside the school there were actual
superheroes there trying to help him and
they were the only ones he unleashed on
I'm just saying that if he has this much
insight he'd be able to recognize an
opportunity
nothing worse than afraid to go wait guy
in case you missed the allegory about
the mutant rehabilitation Wade's here to
properly smash you over the head with it
I've got tumors
Vanessa's weights so his way planning on
just dying or getting his heart right
before he does because I thought that
was the whole point of the sanctimonious
house mom routine before this whole
mission
nice to see some fresh faces of yeah
yeah and what's up with that even though
they were arrested at the same place why
did Wade and Russell end up in the exact
same set he's only 14
don't they have a juvenile block at the
icebox wait they were just in a full-on
prison fight and all they got was sent
back to their fairly plush cell I mean
him aside from the rampant bullying and
the unhygenic conditions there's been a
bad place to stay sure makes a nice
symbolic touchstone for us but how
exactly did Deadpool manage to bring
this token sentimental token token in
with it
token Dan once you get inside this
prison apparently you can go anywhere
guys I'm pretty sure that movie's
telling us that cable killed this guy by
breaking the fuck out of his arm yeah
but the doors literally just opened four
seconds before this blast so why are
both of you all survived Ian stopped
convenient easily short-circuited power
cancelling necklace is convenient from
the future I have three questions then
what dan when was a script written it
hasn't really been popular since 2011
I'm pretty sure the last few minutes of
this action sequence qualifies it as our
mutilation porn and there's a good
chance that it was secretly directed by
David Cronenberg
oh no Wade has been injured they totally
care about this because he's never gonna
recover also cables been spending all
this time on beating up Wade when his
primary mission is currently
incapacitated and standing in the
adjacent prison wait how did wait almost
died again he just hit his head on a
rock and fell into a lake which is
really no worse than all the cable did
to him back at the prison
damn it literally one of the rules that
word selfless a leader they don't know
what that means means just like the
third I don't know what that means joke
in the movie and it just keeps getting
dumber yeah so after that big fight I
guess everyone escaped the frosty
mountain landscape and went back to
their corners Wade went back to the bar
cable back to his hotel room he had
already broken into the prison and
everything up I didn't he go back and
finish the job he was right there and
like that's not a superpower yeah notice
lead dismissal of this becomes a running
joke but is it that crazy of a notion
especially compared to all the others
they're seeing today everything usually
just kind of works out for me like 2008
Ryan Reynolds is god damn it this is
getting congrates
also there's so many medow Ryan Reynolds
jokes in this movie that I'm about to
overdose it made sense in the first
movie there's a really good one at the
end of this movie but we get it
self-deprecating made some terrible
movies Renaissance with this character
can we move on
we interrupt this Deadpool movie to
bring you Conair to cruise control
disease dramatic but no one in the movie
is gonna point out the obvious Star Wars
ripoff they call Colossus on that
Robocop baby why is the mutant that
spits acid wearing a guard that would
keep him from doing so
I mean I know Cyclops has his special
glasses but that's because his gazer
beams are always on and need to be
contained but considering this guy
hasn't even spit acid once I'm not sure
what that's supposed to do for anyone
this scene is amazing and you can bet
your happy ass I'm gonna be taking some
sins off for it but I do have to knock
it a bit for the using a CDC's
thunderstruck in an action sequence
cliche not to mention that only Domino
actually uses her ability to stop her
from dying no one else even tries like
couldn't bedlam somehow manipulate the
electricity around him too anyway you
see where I'm going and for that I'm
only going to remove three sets also the
scene is seriously when it was a script
written a lot of these jokes feel as
stale as TJ Miller's career just ask my
own joke about it we've already seen you
behead and dismember multiple enemies
with all sorts of copious amounts of
hemoglobin spatter are we really
supposed to believe that becoming queasy
is even an option for you at this point
yes it makes for good cinema but why the
put the prison-transport the most
dangerous mutants in the world straight
through the middle of a major
metropolitan area oh yeah wearing the
hood made you totally incognito to
anyone you passed on the street
another amazingly constructed scene uh I
ain't takin sins off for this one since
Domino has already killed dozens of
likely in to suffice Sanders in this
scene along discount Hulk also is this
really the most efficient drop-in for
cable domain Mike wouldn't it be easier
to pick a shorter building just be on
the ground waiting for the convoy he
ends up running after them on the street
anyway
[Music]
even in a movie this ludicrous this
works dan any more of these shots and
I'm gonna have to formally introduce a
Deadpool gets hilariously maimed by a
speeding vehicle please
does anyone else think the cable is
extremely via this job
I mean his sole focus has been to kill
Russell but he keeps fiddle farting
around with secondary characters and
stupid one-liners wait convict
containers aren't bulletproof and why
aren't they already riddled with gun
shots considering the amount of
ammunition that has been unloaded
already in this truck why is this even
possible and have we seen anything in
our time with peewee Kiwi here to think
that he would know how to do this
nah okay I know we have to get the
characters from point A to point B but
there were a lot of inmates in the
icebox did they all fit in one transport
including a special cell for the most
dangerous meeting ever I'll admit it's
mildly frustrating the Deadpool and
Domino both have actual superpowers that
completely short-circuit any attempt at
they survive this but since cable and
Russell were on there too they survived
this I'm gonna rip you in half now I
never thought I'd prefer anything from
x-men The Last Stand but at least their
version of juggernaut was much more
believable than this like myiasis
character even here also why is he so
pissed at Deadpool anyway there are
plenty of other people around here to
maim if he's just in the mood I suppose
there's some explanation in some Rando
comic from 1996 but they can also say
something about it in the movie you know
get me out of here please use my arms as
backpack straps help me understand how
Deadpool experiences pain we know he
feels what happens to him but then does
it immediately go away I mean he's
sitting propped up here completely split
in two wouldn't that's totally sting a
little bit so everyone left cable there
and walked off but they know he's trying
to kill Russell God ban this movie
resets itself constantly with very
little logical reason why is your head
so tiny again stop my hand at least
thirty percent of this movie is copy
pasted dialogue from two years ago it's
like he said Muppet from the waist down
but this time you can see the Muppets
movie repeats the entire pitch meeting
for the happy time murders you picked
around cold future boy is that really
necessary the discussion in the writers
room somehow I made it into the final
script I had two charges one to get me
here one to get me home well that's just
lazy writing is it because it sure is
all better than using the device for a
million different moments you may go
back
and stop the people that took your girl
would you whoa how does cable know about
Vanessa he didn't even get here until
after we'd had moved into the mansion
deal yeah
it's smart jokes like these that make
the sequel far superior to the original
movie I really want to match you know
happy a menacing teen the scene means
absolutely nothing and is exactly the
reason extended editions suck but I said
it throwing more nonsense in just
because you can doesn't make anything
better he said self-referential II say
whatever it is you're here to say what
I'll say is we're the for those guys
during the whole x-force versus cable
fight downtown a few hours ago they
obviously show up at scenarios like that
since they were johnny-on-the-spot when
Russell first went nuclear there
seriously no way to write these assholes
back into the movie until now it takes a
while for Wade to grow his legs back
then they have to go to the mansion on
the way to the orphanage so what took
Russell and juggernaut so long didn't
they leave immediately from the crash
scene to go kill the headmaster sure
they stopped at the Big & Tall place but
how long would that take this movie even
bothered with a timeline pseudo clever
quips only cover up so much trust me I
know it's at this point in the movie
that the score consists of a chorus
repeating holy balls which is funny but
really only in the same way is Billy
lighting his farts on fire in middle
school okay
so we covered blind al being blind
Deadpool breaking the fourth wall
Deadpool being maimed in various ways
poop jokes and open door being nerdy
comic relief did we miss anything else
from the first movie oh I almost forgot
to impale DP in the head during the last
act I would have been embarrassing I
know our focus is supposed to be on the
Deadpool Colossus romance but why
doesn't juggernaut just tear cable and -
right here we saw him do it - Red Dead
reprehend earlier right big CGI sure but
just because you call attention to it
doesn't excuse that awesome considering
they've already been here at least 5
minutes already when exactly does that
whole arbitrary 30-second things start
it's clear that Domino is a martial arts
badass but fine for mutant power it's
luck why would she ever have to do any
training of any kind whatsoever mother
that's racist shock humor that's what
we're doing gosh really you take down
supervillains by shoving a live wire up
their ass and use a force blast to
propel them into water and I knew Putin
was bad but this is a whole new level I
got one more idea it's just a really bad
one even for me sure but considering his
last necklace just shorted out how is
this one even functional after
everything Wade's been through in the
last 20 minutes you're gonna kill
someone today
and it's gotta be me yeah but wait just
got hit with a massive blast of fire
then immediately put the meat in
Colorado shouldn't he be dying or the
burn wounds already bare it worked but
if the bear changed back because the
future is different doesn't that mean
cable would never show up here to begin
with
well I'm gonna need some straws and
Joseph gordon-levitt with Bruce Willis's
knows to explain this aren't I go to
hell time travel you're the worst before
I go this happens way too many times man
what are you going for here straight
comedy actual emotion testing the
audience's patience I'm going with C oh
cool Ted way it looks exactly like that
dude from the proposal just me like you
miss me right I appreciate the effort to
make this ending emotional but given
that this will all be undone in this
overtly insubordinate movie I can't get
on board it's like trying to trick
yourself into having an actual orgasm
when you're in your cousin you time
sliding son of a bitch you did this for
me why is Wayde glad to be saved here
when the last time he went through this
he stopped Colossus from breaking the
necklace and saving it I guess you could
say it's because he saw Vanessa but he
doesn't remember that right and if he
did why did he play dumb the second time
through a family so where are these
assholes going the threat is pretty much
over and they're walking away from the
still alive juggernaut they end up back
at the mansion eventually right are they
going for formal because I don't think
you can fit anymore into the post-credit
footage that's probably a bad idea oh I
know you've created a hilarious but
totally unnecessary post-credits
sequence that feels like Ryan Reynolds
indulging himself a little too much
Passion of the Christ then we beat them
overseas but there's no such things
religion remember the movie interview
with a vampire at what my Tom Cruise and
your my Kristen Dunst Kristen Kirsten I
was fighting a caped badass never
discovered his mom is named Martha to
the Star Wars men are destined to become
their father that had consensual sex
with her sister you need to just keep
living thank you Matthew McConaughey
your words there's got to be some way to
die I just need to die harder these old
guys on the wall who lives here Calista
Flockhart hearing three feet off the
ground to snatch up the nearest muffin
crumb enews live here at a breaking news
did you come quietly or dead it will be
trouble
is there like a sorting my superpower is
just unbridled cancer you have a bow and
arrow
basically Hawkeye piss off a grumpy old
crew with a Winter Soldier on from the
DC Universe and every film is a moment
when the hero hits rock bottom in Cool
Runnings it was when John Kennedy's
prized bobsled broke in Human Centipede
it was when those people signed on to be
in that movie
suck it Williamson specific and us we
have a deal hey big guy
Suns getting real low I want someone I
bet you do brown Panther
you're the statue for me a Seneca
straights in jail you name them Earl I'm
just trying to be a better person
My Name Is Earl I love you
say it
say what you said every time you
tortured me
no you're doing what comes naturally
still they're happy
four or five moments great moments are
born from great opportunity no capes
this is the end story I don't feel so
good
he's my fault she died